In sj, you apply for a ranking within the team and the leader automatically moves up I
see.
Our team doesn't need to worry about
that.  There is also a rule that only the leader can do 53, and in that case, the whole team
will be in high 3, but this doesn't have much to do with Ren-chan
.
I'm the leader, so what kind of
person is weaker than me?
People
I've just finished both of them and I'm going to introduce you This foolishly big degree is
a silly guy This time I'm going to fight with you Horror
Please introduce yourself Nice to meet you I'm m Thank you Nice to meet you
I'm Antenna
I'm fine, so I'll leave the rest to the two young people.
I'm going to have a lot of women, so
everyone,
let's
do our best together.